ce n'est pas un scoop nos forces de
sécurité sont épuisés je tiens ici au
sénat a honoré les fonctionnaires de
police qui ont été ces dernières
semaines me si durement à contribution
l'ordre public et pour moi ancien
adjoint à la sécurité d'une ville
frontalière de belgique
la priorité au sénat j'ai intégré la
commission d' enquête sur l'état des
forces de sécurité intérieure présidée
par notre collègue grosdidier
ce rapport a alerté le gouvernement sur
l'état d'épuisement de la police et de
la gendarmerie
nous avions entendu des dizaines et des
dizaines de policiers gendarmes de tous
niveaux de la hiérarchie
notre cri d'alarmé n'a pas été entendu
par le pouvoir exécutif
les syndicats policiers lancent demain
une opération commissariat morts ils
protestent contre l'insuffisance des
crédits pour la sécurité dans la loi de
finances 2010 9
les sénateurs avaient voté en majorité
contre ce budget qui n'est pas à la
hauteur du travail fourni par nos forces
de l'ordre les fonctionnaires de la
sécurité sont épuisés physiquement sous
la pression opérationnelle inédite en
raison de la menace terroriste à un
niveau toujours élevé à cause de la
pression migratoire continue et aussi de
la radicalisation de la contestation
sociale le stum vous en avez parlé de 25
millions aujourd'hui on a 25 millions
d'heures supplémentaires à payer
augmentera encore en 2019 les locaux
souvent insalubres vont continuer à se
dégrader les véhicules usées vieilliront
encore l' attaque terroriste survenue à
strasbourg la semaine dernière et les
manifestations des gilet jaune depuis
17 novembre ont épuisé nos forces de
sécurité nous avions demandé
l'instauration d'une loi de
programmation pour établir les
conditions de travail dignes et
rattraper l'énorme retard
d'investissement vous avez annoncé à
l'assemblée nationale
question 2 300 euros pour les
fonctionnaires pensez vous que cette
mesure soit suffisant pour atténuer le
mal être de nos forces de sécurité
intérieure vous perdez votre question et
rieur hiérarchie allez-vous répondre aux
besoins du terrain pour vous répondre la
parole et aux secrétaires d'état
produisent d'intérieur monsieur laurent
nunez j'avais la parole monsieur menez
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice d'abord les policiers sont
effectivement fatigués sont fatigués ils
sont motivés déterminés ils l'ont montré
dans la gestion du mouvement d'ordre
public important que nous avons connues
et dans la lutte contre le terrorisme
je ne reviendrai pas sur ce qu'a dit
christophe castaner en répandant à
monsieur le sénateur cazabonne il y à
des efforts importants qui ont été faits
qui sont inscrits au budget de 2010 9
c'est indéniable
ce ne sont pas des mesurettes les
efforts en matière d'équipement
immobilier en matière de véhicules
beaucoup a été fait et puis beaucoup va
être fait sur la suite du quinquennat
notamment en matière de recrutement
puisque à la fin de l'année 2019 nous
aurons enfin enfin reconstitué le volume
de d'effectifs du corps des gardiens de
la paix par rapport à ce qu'il était en
2007 en 2019 on aura retrouvé ce niveau
pour nous c'est important d'arriver à
cet objectif
pour parler de ceux de l'avenir de
demain de tout à l'heure avec christophe
castaner nous allons recevoir les
organisations syndicales nous ne
pouvions pas le faire avant sur ces
mesures là parce que nous étions ça ne
vous a pas échappé en période
d'élections professionnelles et en
période d'élections professionnelles
on ne discute pas de ces sujets mais
nous avons parfaitement en tête avec
christophe castaner il ya effectivement
le sujet du temps de travail
effectivement nous allons nous attachons
nous atteler à ce sujet il ya le sujet
des cycles horaire aussi que nous allons
examiner et bien évidemment le sujet des
heures supplémentaires et christophe
castaner on a parlé nous allons engager
un plan d'apurement mais en veillant à
ce que ne se reconstitue pas un stock et
ça ça sera dans le cadre d'une
q sion courageuses que nous venions
malraux avec les organisations
syndicales
elles attendent beaucoup du temps de
travail nous allons dialoguer avec avec
elle pas plus tard que ce soir
et puis dans les tout premiers jours du
mois de janvier mais nous sommes
déterminés à faire aboutir ses réformes
qui sont très attendus par nos
fonctionnaires de police et nous ne
voulions pas bien évidemment dans ces
mesures également tout ce qui est prévu
pour la gendarmerie nationale mais
pardon ce ne sont pas des mesurettes
nous avons une ambition forte pour le
forces de l'ordre celle d'accroître et
d'augmenter les conditions dans
lesquelles elles exercent un métier
extrêmement difficile je vous remercie